alors on a un talent dans l'antre des
footballeurs de temps
la gueule chuté pour deux concerts ok ok
voilà c'est faire comme un souffle de
plus beaucoup de jus mais je vais
redescendre du manque de tout
contact avril où la montagne regarde pas
guéri
sa frappe enfin l'espace du goût d'un
chien il faut pas trouver jolie s'est
lassé la tipp et de le porter
tél
en plus j'ai un peu dans l'ombre d'un
examen d'or en descente
tu vas réponse bon c'est bon
d'autres voilà c'est pas le compte en
fait c'est joli ça va même un dea c'est
quand même de favoriser voire écrans peu
michel mais c'est peut-être plus dedans
pour sentir la force lors de le truc
et voilà comme ça tu vas rentrer mais la
droite voilà c'est plus convaincant mais
voilà
c'est marrant et en s'écartant de tous
sans doute pour montrer le soleil levant
de son entourage étoiles se faisait pas
assez vaste encore pas tous un peu dans
et si tu faisais un plan doucement
résille ses dessins il est vrai que
maintenant on est dedans dans la force
en plein dans le dense oui toi un truc
qui court maintenant voilà comme ça
qu'ils m'ont tout de suite qu'on le
savait que le plein d'énergie qui sera
fait lundi soir il fait bon y coplan la
raison derrière belle je l'aï des
relieurs c'est joli il a décidé à voir
si je mens je lis ça ira kaplan corps
d'arles
dans le fond d'un puits
tu pouvais